He said you can tackle with us. Read. Well
i brought in my four shilling and ten
punny russian and used to
put it on the table and.
I. I got some employment. They called
it real leaf work and that job was only
in centennial park. They were draining
the ponds the duck ponds down there
and these ponds were gravitated from
a higher level to a lower and by
a system of good drainage they got the water
out of some of them and they set these
relief workers to work with barrow and
shovel and planks and so forth and our
object was to dig out the mud in the bottom
of the duck ponds and shovel it into
the burrows and push the barrow up the
planks and tip it on the perimeter of the
pond. Well i worked there
as a relief worker for
a time. And then. How many days.
How many weeks in on and off did
you get. If my memory serves me correctly
it was a few days for a single man but
a married man with children. He was given
more consideration. And he was one in one
stage it was one in five and that's another
one in four i would just wondering.
That's one week on and for week after
a single man i don't know how many you
know there is so long ago. I have
a faint remembrance of the actual
time but i will add to that. That
one day my mate told me that the
department of main roads board words could
work calling for men up at the local
labour exchange at charring cross waverley
and that they were offered was up
on the queensland border. It was
a single man's job thirty hours a week
two pounds two showings and sixpence
a week. Well i went forward and
i didn't hesitate to register
for such employment. Well
they the department of main
roads board commissioned a
couple of courage is on
a train and when we recruits assembled
at central railway station as
a quite
a number of us to fill those two carriages
and the way we were transported up
to tenterfield and some
of the hardheads in
the assembly of men when they were
informed that the work was sixty miles
out of tenterfield on the tender field to
brisbane highway these hard heads is not
for us. We'll get the next train back so
they they camped they slept around the
railway station that night and they got
the next train back the next day but some
of us that were more discreet
we accepted the future
and we were transported out
to the camp the camp is
a famous place up in that part of
the state called. Core rela core
realer and the actual section of the road
was being constructed by the department
of main roads board was
between oak creek and.
Well i settled in there they department a
main road war board main roads board had
a very good camp set up for
us and we all moved in and.
My health began to improve noticeably
because i had been semi starved
on a fallen tenpenny dole in the city over
a period of eighteen months and my health
began to pick up quickly and i settled
in intent to save money. What sort of work
to do you do on the road. Well the work
consisted of shoveling shoveling into
a fleet of trucks that used to back in on
us in the gravel pit. We used to shovel
this gravel up into the trucks and the
trucks would distribute the gravel along the
newly formed road and incidentally it
was iron stone gravel. It was alluvial
it used to be plowed out of the hillside
by the men on the plows and it was
a readily available material that didn't
cost very much at all and it didn't have
to be napped or spaulding no it was it was
a natural deposit of ironstone and when it
was spread over the newly formed road it
made an ideal surface. Can i take you
back to the quarry. Do you remember
the conditions at the quarry and the
working conditions generally from
a physical point of view. Indeed i do.
And i have often referred to it as the
nearest approach to slavery
that i knew. And without
a doubt. Now ground it is
a very refractory material
to work sandstone is
a child's play in comparison and the
scotchman that were brought out on
a five year contract to process granite
were men that were hardened to it. And
they used to point out to our boys the
necessity of throwing the weight of the body
in with the blow you didn't just tapped you
didn't just tap the tool you lift your
four pound how much head high and you
struck with all your might. Onto
the head of that punch and hence the arduous
nature of the work. Well to see these
got you and many of them passed middle
aged laboring the way they used to do and
getting the results they did spoke volumes
for them. I'd like now to refer to the
key men the key men that were
engaged. To make it possible for the
pylons to be constructed they were
the tools shop. Ps tool shop is
a very special man
a very very special man and
his art is to draw out and
temper. The punch points in such
a way that those points would not snapped.
They would not snap and there were only
about six or eight of these men and they
were key men and i don't mind stating that
the pylons of sydney harbour bridge would
never have been constructed without those
eight men with
a scots australians or talent. Most of
them were scotch one man in particular the
foreman mackenzie mckenzie was his
name and mckinsey used to boast
and say he used to say have you ever
show up. Have you ever shopped for the
brunswick black. That was
a particularly hard. Type of granite to be
found in scotland and any man that could
shop successfully for
the brunswick black was
a highly skilled tool shop.
What did that was that
a lot lot harder than the america and
it extremely hard it was like it was it
had
a carbon content in it which makes
it as black as this instrument
here. Black the tool sharps what
sort of machines. They use.
It was it was hand work. The
punches and the chisels pneumatic
chisels and hand chisels and punches and
the four points are all done by hand
ground. Now all drawn out on the
envoy and done by hand and tempered.
I understand. So it's
a special steel which is drawn out on the
anvil and then tempered afterwards. Yes
indeed the carbon carbon content
of the steel was high and it was
necessary in order for the tool to be durable
went in the special steels that there
are now for that sort of job. Well i
don't think not to the same extent but
normal and long you know i
knew the right type of steel
to see the job through you know what
sort of steel. It was no i can't name it
wasn't tungsten carbide oh oh now that's
a bit technical for me it could have been
very well do you remember in the working
conditions there were there was there any
was there anything to extract the dust.
No indeed. Now that that was what
caused me to become discontented in
myself because. Let dust in
the shed was so pro furious
that you couldn't distinguish
a person say twenty five yards from you
you couldn't distinction distinguish who
that person was especially when the sun's
rays. Came in through the shed. And
made it even more impossible to do it.
Determine who was who. Well this vaporized
dust. We inhaled it. And furthermore
the dust created by the pneumatic
tool was even worse because you
had to get close to your work to
see that you weren't braking and
to see that you were getting
a down to the right level and so forth and
that dust coming away from the pneumatic
tool. You couldn't avoid it. Did
you use any goggles or any yes we
in order to it was imperative. It was
imperative that every man wore the goggles
supplied by the company. Because
the particles of granite that
used to fly were extremely
dangerous and it amazes me
to think that there were not. Eyes.
Well ruined by the flying granite. It
amazes me that they weren't and nobody were
masks. No nobody nobody wore masks. They
weren't encouraged to do so because
the carbonic acid gas that you reach out
from your lungs. You can't get rid of us
sufficiently fast and you bring that
back in again and those masks were very
unhygienic and unhealthy. We didn't use
them. Did you have any changing rooms at
the quarry. No no. There are no such modern
amenities in those days we were dirty
grubby characters but about the toilet
arrangements their toilet arrangements were
up up to standard. There was no sewage
there was none whatsoever. So what was it
pit or chemical. It was i
think they were canisters that the
sanitary man used to take away.
Do you remember how far you the quarry
was from the town and i would say.
Do you remember the granite crashes to
you. Yes indeed the call was what we
call the interior or cause of
the pylons consist of concrete.
Now them material for the concreting of
those cause was crushed in meru. And
the they set up
a very large crusher with jaws of all the
jaws seem to be about three feet wide
and the the granite. But this
crush i used to queue up
used to be picked up off the floor of
the quarry by the crane and dropped on
a platform adjacent to the jaws of this
crusher and the crusher man would bar them
in the best he could into this crusher
and it was a or. Used to make
a terroristic as
a broke up these big plums. Well
those those plums reduced to
a certain size would tumble
down into a skiff. Which was
a. Before wield bucket
underneath there were quite
a number of them perhaps six or
eight of them in one line like
a minute. Your train and ours these buckets
were filled underneath this big crusher
and the try and load was completed the
little rail motor would drag those crushing
up to our and another crusher. Into which
they were tipped and this crusher would
reduce them still finer. And from
the from the base of that crusher
the crossings were elevated by
a belt system with buckets
on it and tipped onto
a rubber tipped into everything
now. Tipped into a grade
a this grade a consisted of
a great circumstance of steel. Say
about six or eight feet in diameter
perforated with holes from end to end
and these holes graduated from large
to gradually smaller at the end and
this greater rotated on the top of this
big bin. So that when the ground. It was
tipped in it was more or less gradually
graded into the several bins. Underneath
this greater and there it. Lied until
the ships came in to take away the processed
granite as well as the crushing was
now one and only boats came in and there
were several of them. If my memory serves
me correctly they were the duty
bell by name the hue bell who was
a senior official of the doorman and
long company in england. So hugely bell.
In addition to sir hugh to bell
there was the doorman long.
Sir dudley dick. These are three that
i can recall there was about half
a dozen of them but these ships
were specially constructed with
a minimum of a motor or
funnel at the back. And
a very little poop in the front but most
of the ship was whole into this hole this
crushed granite would be directed. From
a belt. And when the hold was
sufficiently fooled by this ballast.
The ship would move from that position
to the wharf proper and there was
a sixty foot sixty foot
steel crane operated by jim
kennedy and incidentally i'd like to comment
on this. Jim kennedy before this is
concluded. Jim kind of the use
of operate the crane and these
down as it were all tabulated
all marked with paint
and so that there were a given as
a given section of the pylon was picked
up stone by stone by jim kennedy and
deposited in the hole of this ship.
On top of the crushed ballast. Now
that was the process of getting the ballast
and the dimension stones to sidney.
They have to pack the pack with
stones off before they sailed
know now the stone or simply picked up
and lowered in on top of the ballast and
stabilised by timber
between each stone but it
a very good see you were the load for
a ship to sail with to ember any of the
other crane drivers yes indeed. Yes
campbell
a young man named. Jock
campbell the other crane driver
and i was the one in the quarry was
a no no. Jock. Campbell was in
a crane adjacent adjacent to the one
operated by jim kennedy who was a young man
a very responsible young scotsman very fiery
and so forth and but nevertheless the
other cry and driver. What was out i have
mentioned several right joe separate
he was the quarry driver. Yes he operated
the steam crane in the quarry that he
managed to carry on after the death of of
waters at the back there. Yes yes. Yes of
the game had to go on and i
may mention in passing that
some of the original i would say about
a dozen of the original masons that
arrived on the job. One of them
was jimmy crewe shank jimmy
cruikshank and george walton
and bob celeste's all. And jim kennedy
mason jim kennedy and there were
several of these men got wind of this
contract and they jumped into the breach
immediately. Do you remember the union
and any air union activity down
the quarry. There was a there was
a surprising. Continuity
of work without interruption on the job
but. It was the stone masons you know was
it. Yes yes there was the stone masons
union. I may mention that the stonemasons
rate of pay in sydney was six pounds
ten. But for the country allowance in
america. It brought it up to seven pounds
six and eightpence now that country our
lands and i have heard it said and i have
been through the arbitration proceedings
on this that one of the reasons that they
brought the scots stonemasons and the
italians to masons out was to try and
break the agreement to pay that country
announce. Well this is news
to me but i wouldn't be
a bit surprised with all my due respect
for the scotchman you know it is often
the scotsman is often referred
to as being a bit near etc. Etc.
But that is entirely false of the scotch
people they are according to the studies i
have made of burns. Robert burns and my
actual contact with them they are the most
open hearted humane humanitarians that i
have ever had the pleasure of knowing i
don't i'm not saying that they did scare
or anything like that. I know the country
. Lance was paid but what
and has been alleged by
a number of people is that doorman long
tried to avoid paying the country lands by
importing these masons. Could the job have
been done without the scots masons know
and that dominant long adopters such
a procedure doesn't do them any credit
the credit lies with the scotchman
these highly skilled men as
a matter of fact they had to import them
because they didn't have the skilled labor
here to do the job. Well that's what they
say that's what doorman long said but it
was alleged by other people that they
imported them not to because they couldn't
get local masons but because they wanted
to avoid paying the the country lands.
Well that is
a matter for conjecture conjecture but i
think myself. The fact remains that they
didn't have the skill men in this country
to complete the contract. Well that's
what dominates say. So we'll have to accept
that then. But the rumor went around
and there is
a certain well i know that as the men came
off the ships that the union signed them
all up so that the country allowance was
paid you know. But the state what had
happened was this that the doormen long
had forgotten to calculate the country
allowance into the cost of their contract.
So they went back to the government and
said well you're responsible for the rise
and fall in wages. What about paying us
this and the government and bradfield said
no no no no that's that's our country
allowance is not wages you should have put
that in the contract in the first place
so they say well and that case we can we're
not gonna pay the country. The country
allowance from the stonemasons unions that
well you've got to pay that the country
lads at their round about that time the.
The men started coming in from scotland
that is
a live and the stand mason's union signed
them up so that the country lands was
paid and one long lost out. So you know
that's the story as far as that's concerned
but it was alleged that they actually
imported them to avoid paying the country
lands but it seems that this is not so
and that what they said was that they
couldn't get enough local mason so in
actual fact they did have to import them do
you remember whether there was was used
amongst the labourers down there. Yes yes
the a.w.
Was well represented down
there and the men were well
organized as
a matter of fact my father being the
democrat that he was used to give the i
w you. Organizer. What we called
a shakedown for the night at our private
dwelling in the town. Do you remember the
name of the organisers i can't recall his
name. But this was my first introduction
to democratic thinking
because this man used to
live live with my father the a.w.
You paper called the worker
and that paper what edited by
a famous philosopher in this country
an englishman. Henry the boot.
He edited that paper for forty years of
his life. Yes. Now do you remember any
of the job delegates shot or the shop
delegates. Yes there was one in particular
he was an italian and he is
a member of the moloch so moloko family
who have operated as masons in this city
for
a couple of generations. His name was
victor my locker. He spoke english fluently
and whenever there was any disruption at
the quarry. Victor was brought forward to
interpret to the italians the proceedings
of that meeting and whether italians
member of the stand masons or the a.w.
They were members of the stonemasons union.
Yes well that and so there was there
was
a unifil unified union front very
much so and factor since the
scotchman were brought out on
a five year contract. Namely that if they
remained. Until the completion of the
contract that their fares would be paid
back home. Well presumably some of these
are tallien came from north italy and they
were probably brought out under contract
from italy. Did you see anything of
the scots being paid in gold. No
i never set eyes on gold in all my lifetime.
Several people in sydney have said
that the stonemasons were paid in gold.
That is utterly false. Well you know the
story is that the that they used to come
the stand masons used to come up with the
. Gold sovereigns and drink in the imperial
on notions point and that they would
put the gold in the bar.
That is irresponsible
thinking. Did you. Did you come across
any of the masons who worked in sydney.
Yes yes and there's one in particular
that is worthy of comment and notice
i worked with this man in the monumental
firm of arnold and company in paddington
they have been established there for about
100 years. Well this amount i worked
alongside of had worked in mariah his name
was william summers. Yes i would double
m e
r s william summers was one of the most
experienced and highly skilled and authentic
men on the question of granite. Now
this man was so acknowledged that the
the representatives of doormen and long
before they decided on the whereabouts of
acquiring him. They selected
sometimes as being the authentic
mason to advise them as to
a location and the quality of granite.
Well some of us went down with the
two or three of the executives. Presumably
they were engineers that didn't know
much about granite and some of us went in
about into the hinterland behind maria
up around nelligan way you told me and all
around there. But the location wasn't
suitable and they ended up at maruja yes
but that was picked by bradfield from
a number of public works quarry wasn't it.
But the maria quarry. I don't doubt that
because the proximity the proximity of
the quarry to the actual river. You
couldn't have bettered it anywhere in the
state. Yes i know that was one of the
that when one of the reasons. Do you
ever hear or remember another one of the
stonemasons who worked in sydney.
Tom mackay. Macaire that my client
a very very ancient name. I
know about was familiar with mackay he
didn't work at murray. Incidentally he was
up in sydney all the time and he was well
known as the pipe manager for the. For
the caledonian society in
sydney. Mackay. He led the. He
led the band with the bridge workers in
the opening procession as well. So i just
wondered if you know.
So well i haven't any
indelible impression as of
a fellow but i did work at knox grammar
school for about three years and the pipe
major there was named mackay. But it might
have been the same i know later on in
his life he kept
a garage five double. Oh i couldn't say
that i recollect it like him. Did you hear
of any of the names of the other any of the
other stern masons that works in sydney
i understand there were four. Yes yes
yes. In addition to william summers in
arnold's yard in at paddington alongside
of him worked. Jimmy mac miller and jimmy
macmillan was i worked alongside of jimmy
mcmillan as an apprentice in the maria
sheds do you remember another one.
Another one that came up to
sydney. Now my memory fails
me there. Well you've done very well
because it. You've got the two the jimmy
mcmillan and the other one was some what
was his first bill somers if i had more
time to think i could recall to mind
some motions that pulled out of
maria subsequently and well the third one.
We have is time. So we've got three out
of the four in actual fact the names
of the ones that worked in sydney. You
remember the other delegates up
there and it. Maria. Yes the a
w delegate was percy manning
and my father robert
crap you member any of the others. Here the
stern masons delegate was arthur woody
and the secretary in
sydney was richard warren
and was assigned to thank you very much.